my name is Laurie Santos I'm an
associate professor of psychology at
Yale University
so the capuchins always study are really
distantly related but they're actually a
great model for human cognition for a
couple of reasons one is that being a
primate that kind of branched off about
35 million years ago they actually tell
us something about what human evolution
human cognition probably looked like a
really long time ago so it actually
gives us insight not just into our very
recent phylogenetic past as studies with
chimpanzees might do but capuchins
actually tell us something about you
know really phylogenetically old
similarities that we might share with
other primates
one cool thing about primates is that
they like us are extremely social
creatures so they grow up in the context
of social groups they're around other
conspecifics other individuals of the
same species and the social
relationships they form really affect
their entire lives so it affects you
know what kind of food they're gonna get
you know based on who they hang out with
and what rank they are you'll
high-ranking individuals have easy
access to food whereas low ranking
individuals might have to wait their
turn it affects the kind of meeting
success they can get you know the kind
of Alliance is the they form and the way
they sort of set up their little social
groupings actually can you know affect
just how well they do in terms of
natural selection so social groups are
really important for most primate
species
one of the reasons it took scientists so
long to figure out how to ask monkeys
about what they know about other minds
is that oftentimes researchers were
trying to set up studies that might make
sense to human but probably don't make
sense to a monkey so one kind of study
actually involved a setup where a human
was trying to help a primate get a piece
of food that was hidden so different
pieces of food are hidden the monkey
can't see where they are but the human
was kind of looking and pointing at one
of these pieces of food in general
primates did really badly on this year
embarrassingly badly even with training
they kind of never got it but that
actually makes sense like never in a
monkey's life would ever intentionally
cue a human experimenter to wear a piece
of food was this was just a situation
that was totally weird so the insight
that we as scientists had was that well
let's use the situations that monkeys
are naturally using to deceive us maybe
this is where they'll actually show us
they understand something and you know
now 5-10 years later there's you know
tons of studies suggesting exactly that
one reason it's important to actually
study the evolutionary origins of say
you know our economic troubles and so on
is that oftentimes when we learn some
behavior or some bias is built in by
natural selection
it means it's actually really hard to
overcome so you know it's really hard to
convince people that cheesecake doesn't
inherently kind of taste good right you
know sugary fatty things are just built
in by natural selection we're gonna like
them you know by the same token you know
it's really hard to convince people you
know I'm not to flinch when there's kind
of some moving object coming at your
head or you're some scary spider or so
on these are these kinds of biases that
are built in via natural selection
they're pretty old and they're also
really hard to turn off you even when we
were aware of them the problem in the
economic domain is my guess is that the
biases we're seeing in US and in monkeys
are going to be equally hard to turn off
but these are ones that it's hard to
even be aware of how strong they are so
I think one of the important things
about seeing these kinds of errors and
monkeys is just not only are they old
but they're gonna be really hard to get
over
so policies that try to deal with these
biases it might be well-served to say
look let's just assume these biases are
in place and how can we design policies
that can accept them and sort of deal
with them as they are
one thing we're really interested in is
whether monkeys have the opportunity to
think twice right know we can you know
experience this bias and succumb to it
we can also be very meta about it and
think about you know well you know I can
talk to you now about these biases you
know the monkeys probably aren't you
know sitting around the forest talking
to each other about the kinds of
economic biases they have so the the
fact that we can kind of think twice paw
is kind of inhibit they sort of
prepotent or the sort of instinctual
bias that gives us a weapon against
these sorts of biases but in some sense
we have to know they're there in the
first place to actually implement these
kind of wait wait wait let me stop pause
think about it and try to come up with
the right decision so I think awareness
that we have these biases in these
everyday situations and that we're
really affected by them is actually very
important
our newest line of work is actually
trying to explore whether or not the
monkeys share some of the aspects of
human social cognition that we're not
very proud of so these are things like
the fact that we are very very
prejudiced even when we don't realize we
are we have these implicit biases
against out group members against
individuals of different religions
different races and so on and these
biases play themselves out in really
insidious ways we'd really like to know
how these biases work but there are lots
of possibilities on the table for where
they come from right you know we grow up
in a biased society there are lots of
kind of cultural influences that are
biases are these the real culprits or is
it something a little bit deeper is it
something maybe older that might be
harder to override so we actually
started studying whether the monkeys
share some of our human-like prejudice
against the out-group our first study
really just asked this in a really
simple way we said do monkeys
spontaneously distinguish between guys
that are in their in-group and guys that
are in the out-group so the experiment
was super simple we did this down at our
field site in Puerto Rico where we study
rhesus monkeys monkeys free range around
and we sort of showed up with a sort of
big billboard which had come two covers
at the end of it when we opened the
covers that had two pictures of
different monkeys one guy from their
group and one guy from the out group and
the really simple measure was do the
monkeys increase their vigilance they
kind of get worried about and stare at
more at the guy who's in our group again
this is you know first trial of monkeys
I've ever seen this sort of weird
billboard set up but we found the
expected result one you might expect
from humans which is that spontaneously
the monkeys actually direct their
vigilance towards the guy who's in their
out group the the worrying thing is this
seems very similar to the way that
humans can devote their attention to out
group members and in our next line of
studies we want to see well you know
they're just kind of looking longer at
these guys where do they actually treat
them differently in other words do they
associate them with bad things in their
environment and there's a long line of
studies in people trying to look at
whether people do this implicitly
there's a study known as the implicit
association test which basically asks
you to do a couple categorizations
you're doing you're categorizing good
and bad words and you're also
categorizing in-group and out-group
members you know say you know your
religion versus a different religion and
using this task
researchers have shown that it's
actually very hard to categorize your
in-group with the bad words and your
out-group with the good words are
actually slower and you make more errors
when these categories don't match up
suggesting that you know even though we
don't like to think we do we have these
biases against our group members that
can play out in these really simple
contexts so we basically did the same
categorization measure with our monkeys
we give them kind of a series of
different pictures that either matched
in their valence so they were all kind
of good images to the monkey so they
were all bad images to the monkeys the
idea is in those cases the monkey should
get bored kind of good thing good thing
good thing or a bad thing bad thing bad
thing or we set up a list of pictures
where the valence is differed and one of
these cases was one of pictures of their
in-group members and pictures of bad
things in this case scary spiders and
what you found is that when the valence
is were inconsistent so in other words
when they in group members were paired
with these bad spiders that actually
increased the monkeys processing time
suggesting that they don't treat those
categories the same way however when you
put out group members with bad things
like spiders they actually process them
very quickly suggesting that to a monkey
a member of its out group is basically
in some sense equivalent emotionally or
in terms of its valence to this you know
scary predator a spider creature same
thing when we did when we tried to look
at positive images so in group members
the monkey seemed to process
like fruits really positive you know
good images that they want to approach
an income near but not so without group
members so when you give them pictures
of out-group members paired with fruits
it actually takes them a lot of
processing time what it seems like is
that spontaneously the monkeys are
setting up the same associations that we
humans are where they're treating output
members like negative things and
in-group members like positive things
four monkeys in groups and out groups
are very simple for humans it's not that
simple right you know we can form
groupings based on all kinds of you know
really stable social groups like our
race our gender and so on but we also
form groups you know on the fly you know
we can be Red Sox Minh Red Sox fans or
Yankees fans you know I could be the
grey shirt wearing person you could be a
different color shirt wearing person
humans can turn these things on really
spontaneously for the monkeys it depends
on how they're born so the monkeys in
this population are born into a
particular social group it's based on
who they are related to so they're born
into a particular group the females stay
in that group for their whole lives and
the male's actually switch groups so the
monkeys provide this really cool window
because the females live in these very
stable groups that they're gonna be in
for their whole lives
where the male's actually switch and so
the male is actually or in one group for
a certain stage of their lives and then
switch to a new group so they kind of in
some sense have to update their
information about what group they're and
who they like and who they don't like
and so on
our conclusion from this recent line of
work suggests that first that monkeys
actually spontaneously form associations
form categories about groups in the same
way that humans do
so the perhaps the exact same thing that
humans do when they think about
individuals from a different race
the monkeys are doing when they're
thinking about individuals from a
different social group beyond just the
fact that they categorize them they also
seem to have valence them in the same
way as humans do namely they team that
they tend to think of the in-group is a
positive entity maybe actually devote
resources more to the in-group and they
think of the out-group as a negative
entity the thing in humans is that we
know that this is true implicitly often
explicitly people won't express these
prejudices but it suggests that whatever
is going on at the implicit level might
be a process that's evolutionarily quite
old and to us that suggests that getting
over these kinds of biases might even be
harder than social psychologists have
thought before the monkey work is cool
because what we think it's telling us is
something about the roots of human
sexism human racism human ageism
basically any form of human group ISM
we're seeing the undercurrents of this
in the same cognitive processing we're
studying in the monkeys
the primate researcher is also a little
disingenuous when they talk about
primary tool use because the the kinds
of tools that primates use tend to
really impress us in you know first of
all they use tools which we didn't think
they did you know over 40 years ago now
we see evidence they use tools in all
kinds of different contexts your tools
to get at food tools to attract other
may it's you know tools to kind of
sponge off seats and climb up trees
tools for all kinds of different things
they even seem in some cases to have
tool kits so kits of tools that they'll
use for one particular function where
they'll use different parts of the same
tool and multiple different tools and
this really impresses us but this is
kind of the limit of it you know there's
nothing like there kinds of complex
tools or technologies that we see in
humans so one way to classify the
difference is that primary is actually
do seem to use tools you know get it's
ones that are relatively complicated for
other species but they don't seem to
have technologies in the way so that we
do in the sense that they don't have a
sort of cumulative evolution of
different tool cultures that in some
sense take on a life of their own where
multiple individuals are contributing to
this the kinds of designs that we come
up with in one generation get passed on
and improved on by the other generation
again you see little bits of this but
nothing at the scale that we have in our
own species
it's still a big puzzle as to why we're
the only species that has cumulative
technology in the way that we do one
answer that seems to be coming up might
have to do with the way that humans
imitate other individuals so there was
recently a study by Andy white and his
colleagues trying to look at the ways
that human children imitate a person
acting on a tool versus the way that
chimpanzees imitate and so the
experiment went like this both children
and chimpanzees were given a little
puzzle box
it was opaque they couldn't see how it
worked but they get to watch a human
demonstrator open it up and the steps to
open it upward of two parts first it
involves kind of tapping the puzzle box
on the top and this sort of way and then
it involves opening a door and taking
out a tree so both kids and chimpanzees
after seeing this can follow the
experiment are perfectly so they do the
tapping part open the door get the tree
now you do the same search setup except
instead of the box being opaque it's now
transparent and it's obvious to both the
child the child subjects and the
chimpanzees that the whole tapping part
at the top is just bogus like the
tapping doesn't actually go anywhere
it's like kind of a false top so you can
see as you're watching a person do this
that you don't need to do this all you
have to do is open the door when you
give this puzzle to chimpanzees they do
what you might expect to be the smart
maneuver they're just kind of cut to the
chase and open the door and take the
tree
want you to do this with human children
however what you find surprisingly and
perhaps embarrassingly for our species
is that the human children slavishly
imitate the person they see so even
though they can clearly see you that
this you know poking in the top is a
stupid gesture they do it anyway what it
seems like is that humans really are
paralyzed by watching the actions of
others actually seems to change our
causal intuitions about how different
objects work this is bad when people do
really stupid things on boxes and open
them the wrong way but it's great for
the cumulative evolution of Technology
because it means you don't have to know
the physics or the the causal aspects of
how something works you just basically
follow somebody's actions do that
yourself then you can pass on these
kinds of cultures to the next generation
and so in some sense the fact that
chimpanzees don't rely on social and
as much as they seem to rely on physics
actually means they might not learn
about technologies in the same fast way
that humans do because if you think
about the kinds of technologies that we
deal with you know they're often so
physically complex that we can't explain
them you know I use my iPhone every day
but I have no idea how it works you know
I slide the little bar and that's what I
understand but for chimpanzee is all of
the technologies they work have physics
that are really obvious so affordance is
that they could see that anyone could
see somehow actually paying attention to
social information more than physics
might have allowed us to go beyond the
kind of obvious way things work to new
kinds of technologies
oh yeah I think science is very sexy I
mean there are a lot of big scientific
puzzles when it comes to sexual
reproduction you know why do we choose
to have sex it'd be much easier to just
kind of you know Budd little clone you
know it saves lots of time and energy
waste and disease and all these things
but you know many many animals in the
animal kingdom actually put in the time
and energy and risk the disease and you
know all the pains and heartache to
actually sexually reproduce so it's a
big puzzle in evolutionary biology and
then when you start looking at the
different ways animals go about sexual
reproduction all the different ways they
go about finding mates and you know
strategizing to get mates and convincing
individuals to mate with them and so on
you know it's kind of just fascinating
to see all the strategies that are out
there and in many ways humans are real
outliers in this so it's it's fun to
look at the kinds of techniques that we
see across the animal kingdom
well humans are very funny species when
it comes to sexual reproduction we're
very weird relative to our closest
living primate relatives the other Apes
so we for the most part seem to be a
pair bonded species in other words a
male and a female get together and form
this pair bond and kind of cooperatively
rear their young there's nothing really
like that in the the rest of the great
ape species in chimpanzees are our
closest living relative you see lots of
multi-male multi-female reproductive
behavior meaning you know females are
mating with multiple males males are
mating with multiple females but also in
chimpanzees you also see that males and
females just aren't interested in sex
during the period where females aren't
very productive so female chimpanzees
advertise their receptivity the period
where they're fertile by having this
huge sexual swelling that kind of blows
up and males are kind of only interested
during this period somehow humans you
know unlike our closest living relatives
have kind of gotten rid of this you know
human females of course don't go around
advertising with you know really robust
blown-up read sexual skins when they're
receptive which is a bit of a puzzle you
know why did we lose this trait just in
the last seven million years you know
these are the kinds of things that hang
on for long periods of time in primate
evolution so the fact that we got rid of
this really quickly is a bit of a puzzle
so kind of weird relative so they're
closely related primates when it comes
to sex and our sexual behavior the our
other closest so we have two closest
living primate relatives it's a tie
between chimpanzees so common
chimpanzees and their sister species
bonobos and chimpanzees and bonobos
greatly differ in their own sexual
behavior bonobos are sort of the make
love not war kind of primate they tend
to be way less violent and aggressive
than chimpanzees and one of the
behaviors that allows them to overcome
that is the fact that they're very
sexually oriented so in a lot of the
situations that would cause aggression
in chimpanzees bonobos actually resort
to having sex to kind of diffuse any of
the anxiety or the stress about the
situation so it's another puzzle for
humans is that
we have one of one of our closest living
relatives is very aggressive very
warlike you kind of a lot of the stuff
that we explicitly say we kind of don't
like as much about the human species our
other closest Driven living relative is
very peaceful you a very kind of social
sexual oriented has lots and lots of
female bonds there's a bit of a puzzle
in the field of you know what parts of
these two guys did the humans get you
know we more like chimpanzees are more
like bonobos still big puzzles in the
field of primate cognition
the human reproductive system is one
that we don't really have a great grasp
on because in some sense we pair-bond
for the most part but across all human
cultures there's really a push to push
me so in most human cultures there are
at least some males who take on multiple
mates and have you know multiple mating
partners but not nearly to the degree
that you see in chimpanzees the way you
can tell this morphologically is by the
size of the testes relative to body size
so chimpanzee testicles relative to body
size are just like enormous you know
you'd blush to see the size of these
things you know not nearly the same
ratio as you see in humans however
humans have a larger testicle to body
size ratio than you what you might see
in other primates where we know the
females don't kind of sleep around like
as the casein gorillas so the human
mating system is kind of somewhere in
between we're sort of pair-bonded
there's this push to polygyny so there's
a push of males taking on multiple
female partners but there also seems to
be a push towards polyandry in other
words females taking on multiple male
partners or else why would males cannot
grow these big testicles to kind of
compete at the level of sperm so so
where this funny puzzle in terms of why
humans might pair bond one of the pushes
towards pair bonding in the animal
kingdom
has to do with the kind of size and
cumbersome meanness of your offspring so
the the taxa where you see that most
pair bonding is in birds you can see
this in kind of the standard sort of
march of the Penguins are the two
parents that have to sort of very cutely
take care of the kids but it's true in
birds because the offspring actually
require a lot of work there's extremely
fragile egg you know that's very tasty
and you have to defend it from predators
and so on and it actually requires both
parents to actually incubate the egg you
know protect it and so on the idea is
the same might be true of humans human
infants are born incredibly pro-social
precocial so human infants are born
incredibly precocious much more so than
you know are they're close primary
relatives you know they're they're
pretty fragile you know if you just left
the human baby newborn there for a long
time you know wouldn't do so well
the thought is maybe this human
pair-bonding actually came as a result
of the fragile nests of human infants
you know in that it might require two
parents to actually take care of these
offspring but again you know these are a
lot of just so stories out there you
know it's really hard to figure out
exactly why we have the reproductive
system we have and you know it's a
complicated one that we can't pin down
you know the sad thing that I mentioned
in my course is it we know much more
about the reproductive systems of pipe
fish and you know swans and lions than
we do about our own species which is
kind of pathetic
the animal kingdom is full of amazing
amazing behaviors typically in which
males are trying to attract females so
most of the time through the animal
kingdom females are the ones who tend to
be very choosy so they pick between
different males based on their
attributes in part because males
typically don't donate much other than
their good sperm and their good genes so
if he mates
females tend to care a lot about how
good a male looks you know how awesome
his song is how great his dances and so
on and this leads to a pressure for
males to kind of Ratchet it up and have
you know a bit of an arms race in terms
of how awesome their dances and their
song is and so on some of my favorite
examples of kind of males ratcheting it
up are cases of there's a species known
as the buff breasted Sandpiper it's this
otherwise kind of drab looking Brown
Arctic bird it's a drab looking because
it lives in the Arctic very hard to get
food and do everything but it kind of
allows for its beauty to come out in
really strange ways and one of these
ways is that it has an incredibly
attractive armpit
so it's armpit is very white very clean
and it will do flash displays for
females where males will kind of get out
in a field and sort of flash its armpit
and if the females like the armpit they
kind of fly from miles and miles and
then they'll kind of if you do this
wonderful armpit display in the females
you know fall for it this is wonderful
but you can tell you know kind of which
males have the sexy armpits but you know
which ones they're kind of flashing all
the females are though they're also
other species in which males do
incredible dances to woo females there's
a species of bird known as a mannequin
in which males actually do a really
elaborate dancing display that actually
involves two partners so there's a kind
of senior male who gets to mate with the
females and another male who apprentices
with him and has to learn the dance and
the female picks on the dance of both of
them even though the senior guy gets the
girl but then eventually their
Apprentice will kind of inherit the
dancing court and and get the lady
some of our monkey economics work
suggests that the biases we see in
humans in particular the fact that we
think about economic questions from a
relative rather than absolute standpoint
those kinds of biases are deeply
ingrained in us probably evolutionarily
old and hard to overcome what this means
is that we got to start taking these
biases seriously in the policy
implication or or even just the
implication for laypeople you know
trying to make economic decisions is to
realize that these factors are at work
so one thing we've learned is that the
monkeys actually pay a lot of attention
to reference points so arbitrary
information that just sets a price for
you and you care about whether you know
the actual price you're gonna pay is
less or more than that you know so
advertisers do this to us all the time
you can't walk into you know a grocery
store or a department store without
seeing you know was like $300 now only
199 right we're affected by these things
even though we really like to think that
we aren't and you know if you think
about you know other things that are
evolved other evolved biases we have
like you know our passion for cheesecake
and our hatred of scary things and so on
but we're really gonna have a hard time
overcoming these sorts of biases and so
the policy implications are first just
that should we allow these kinds of
things out there probably we're never
gonna overcome that you know probably
these these kinds of things are gonna be
there but as a decision maker you should
really realize that they're there and
understand that your choices are really
being affected by these pieces of
information there are a set of folks who
are really pushing the view that we need
to take these biases seriously so folks
like dick Thaler and Cass Sunstein who
wrote this recent book nudge that I
think thankfully is having a big effect
saying that look we need to take these
kinds of things seriously because
pretending that we don't have these
biases means that we set up these choice
structures as they call them choice
architectures that are influencing
people's behavior even though we don't
think that they do so they have a case
of you know consider a lunch line when
you have different foods in different
orders and let's say that we could
figure out for sure that the first piece
of food is going to affect what you
by which police the food should we put
first well we could be paternalistic and
put the broccoli first you know we could
say no we're gonna ignore that and put
the the Cheesecake first and so on
but you know one of the foods has to go
first or we have to decide to be random
every day and switch it up you know when
we set up policies we set up these
structures that have to have a default
option that have to sway choices somehow
and so the question is you know how do
we want to sway them and realizing how
these biases work and that because of
our work with the monkeys they might
really be hard to override I think
suggest that in fact we need to take
these kinds of policy suggestions really
seriously and deal with the question
that you know we have to set these
policies up somehow and we know that how
we set them up is going to affect
choices you know what should we really
decide to do
there's lots of really old work in
social psychology suggesting that the
way other people act can have a really
strong influence on us so there are a
set of studies back in the 50s about
conformity so they typically go
something like this you're in a big
group of people you're asked to make a
decision about something really
arbitrary that you should know like
which line is longer this line or this
line and what you're faced with is a
group of people who are all saying the
incorrect answer and what you find is
that striking number of subjects won't
go against what the group norm is
suggesting you know sometimes so
strongly that it actually override what
you actually thought yourself so the the
presence of other people and what other
people expresses their preferences or
their knowledge and so on
it can affect us in a really deep way
again you know typically for positive
aspects you know these are probably the
things that allowed us to develop rich
cultures and so on but they also have a
negative aspect as well so I think the
implication is that we really just need
to realize that this bias is there
realize that we're affected by these
things and and hopefully that'll let us
get better about it often a lot of the
biases that we we study another
psychologists study you know the real
problem with them isn't necessarily just
that they're there that we make errors
or we show these illusions and so on
it's that we really have a strong
feeling that we're not affected by them
so when you show these kinds of biases
and errors and in demos in class
students who succumb to them are shocked
and students who just hear about people
succumbing to them kind of laugh like
you know I wouldn't show that bias yeah
so I think one of the the big problems
with this work is actually convincing
people no no you know you you will fall
prey to these things even though it
really feels like you won't so the the
hope is that the one key work shows that
you know if these biases are really that
old you know maybe they're more powerful
than we thought maybe we really should
pay attention to how they're affecting
our behavior
we really are affected by our own
expectations so what we taste when we're
eating a particular meal or drinking a
particular wine is really based not on
the actual taste of that thing but our
expectations about what we know from the
past so there's you know a series of
studies in the economics literature
showing that if you think a wine is
actually worth you know a hundred
dollars and but it's really worth ten
dollars it actually tastes differently
to you based on your expectation because
you know something about you know the
fact that or you like to think that $100
wines taste better than you know $10
wine so they wouldn't charge that much
and so on so our expectations actually
shape the way we experience things not
just kind of what we expect that our
real subjective experiences so the
realizing that your perhaps can actually
allow you to focus more on your
subjective experience and maybe overcome
that bias down the line
the information we pay attention to
tends to be very local and it tends to
be very relative and that can a lot of
times our decisions are so based on that
that it forces us to ignore really
relevant historic data so one of my
favorite examples of this is that people
typically invest more in bonds than they
should for their rate of return that
they should be investing more in stocks
because if you look historically over
the last hundred years there's on
average about 7% extra boost that you
get to your investment by investing in
stocks rather than bonds however people
don't you know pay attention to
investments over a hundred years they
look locally and stocks have the you
know unfortunate thing is that they
often go out but they're very volatile
you know so sometimes you see that the
stock goes into the red and that's an
extremely salient but very local and
very relative situation yet it affects
our behavior a lot so much so that a
Nobel prize-winning economists who won a
Nobel Prize for actually coming up with
an algorithm for how you how you should
put stocks and bonds together when folks
looked at his own portfolio he didn't do
that he actually invested more in bonds
than he should have to so you know even
people who should really know better you
know who should have the historic
approach looking over a long time skills
aren't they - are falling prey to these
really local really relative kinds of
comparisons